aquí tenemos la reacción general para
una hidra oración oxidación empezamos
con un al que no y en el primer paso
este es nuestro paso de hidro por acción
estamos añadiendo verano que es bh 3 y
tetra hidro furano que esté hf nuestro
segundo paso es la oxidación donde
añadimos peróxido de hidrógeno y una
fuente de iones hidróxido y podemos ver
lo que obtendremos como nuestro producto
vamos a añadir 1h y un h a través de
nuestro doble enlace así que el doble
enlace se va en lo h se añade a uno de
los carbonos y el h se añade al otro
carbono como sabemos a qué carbono se
agregue lo h ya que carbono se agregue
el hidrógeno pensemos en la región
química para esta reacción y resulta ser
una adición anti marco único lo que
significa que el lo h se añade al
carbono menos sustituido para entender
esto tenemos que ver el mecanismo para
una hidro votación oxidación el cual
veremos en el siguiente
ya que es demasiado largo para un solo
vídeo también en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a ver los detalles acerca del
estéreo química para esta reacción
resulta ser una adicción sin lo que
significa que el h y el h se añaden en
el mismo lado muy bien veamos un ejemplo
de hidro votación oxidación así que
vamos a comenzar con este al que no de
aquí muy bien sabemos que vamos a añadir
1 h y un h a través de nuestro doble
enlace y sabemos que el h se añade al
carbono menos sustituido así que
ubicamos a los dos carbonos en el doble
enlace son este carbono de aquí y este
otro de aquí cuál de esos carbonos es el
carbono - sustituido
obviamente el carbono de aquí arriba es
el carbono - sustituido por lo que es
ahí donde vamos a añadir el h así que
voy a dibujar el producto estamos
agregando el h en el carbono superior
justo aquí es este carbono en magenta y
el hidrógeno se añadirá a este carbono
aquí abajo
no voy a dibujar al hidrógeno pero es
aquí en donde se añadiría este es
nuestro producto realmente no tenemos
que preocuparnos por la stereo química
al momento de dibujar a nuestro producto
ya que este carbono en magenta no es un
centro quiral y el carbono en rojo
tampoco es un centro que irá muy bien
ahora vamos a ver un ejemplo en el que
si tenemos que preocuparnos por la
stereo química de nuestros productos así
que para este al que no de aquí observó
a los dos carbonos a través del doble
enlace este carbono y este carbono sé
que esto es una hidra oración oxidación
así que voy a añadir mi o h al carbono
menos sustituido y este por supuesto en
la derecha es el carbono - sustituido
pensando únicamente en la región química
voy a dibujar a mí o h en ese carbono
así que voy a dibujar mi producto no
estamos considerando a la estéreo
química todavía así que el h se añade al
carbono en magenta que era nuestro
carbono - sustituido y cuando observamos
a nuestro
este es nuestro carbono este carbono que
acaba de circular es un centro girar por
lo tanto esta vez si tenemos que
preocuparnos por la stereo química este
carbono de aquí en la izquierda no es un
centro final así que no tenemos que
preocuparnos por el carbono en rojo
tenemos que preocuparnos solamente por
el carbono en magenta así que vamos a
pensar en la stereo química de una
adicción sin es decir la adición de
lachay de lo h en el mismo lado así que
tenemos que pensar en este al que nadie
aquí y en estos carbonos que marque en
amarillo estos carbonos tienen
hibridación sp2 así que la geometría
alrededor de estos carbonos se es plana
y cuando añadimos nuestro h y nuestro h
estamos cambiando la hibridación de esos
carbonos a una hibridación sp3 muy bien
dibujemos uno de nuestros productos aquí
así que obtendríamos uno de los posibles
productos al añadir el h y él lo hace en
el mismo lado los voy a dibujar con
cuñas así que aquí está nuestro
hidrógeno
una cuña y aquí está nuestro h con una
cuña ya sé en qué carbono añadir a cada
uno porque ya resolvimos esa parte antes
sabemos que lo h se añade a este carbono
del lado derecho y sabemos que el h se
añade al carbono de aquí en rojo muy
bien así que estoy mostrando una
adicción sin de mi hidrógeno y de mi h
por lo cual dibujamos a ambos con cuñas
ahora pensemos en lo que está unido a
estos carbonos aquí arriba tenemos este
carbono en magenta que es este carbono
de aquí que más está unido a este
carbono bueno hay un hidrógeno unido a
él por lo que si pienso en la estéreo
química ese hidrógeno debe de estar
alejándose de mí en el espacio para este
producto estamos pasando de un carbono
con hibridación sp2 en nuestro al que no
a un carbono con hibridación sp3 así que
este hidrógeno se está alejando de
nosotros ahora pensemos en este otro
carbono voy a dibujar a este otro
carbono en color rojo es este carbono de
aquí
que además está unido a este carbono
pues tenemos un grupo metilo y si este
hidrógeno está saliendo hacia mí
entonces este grupo metilo debe estar
alejándose de mí así que tenemos un
grupo metilo alejándose de nosotros en
el espacio este es uno de nuestros
posibles productos voy a dibujarlo de la
forma en que estamos acostumbrados a
verlo voy a dibujar el o h viniendo
hacia nosotros en el espacio muy bien el
o h está viniendo hacia nosotros así que
este es uno de nuestros posibles
productos muy bien para nuestros otros
productos podría mostrar el h y el h
añadiéndose en el mismo lado pero esta
vez los dibujaré con guiones voy a
dibujar a nuestros carbonos aquí y esta
vez el h lo voy a mostrar añadiéndose
con guiones y el h también lo
mostraremos con guiones lo que esto
significa es que este hidrógeno de aquí
tendría que tener una cuña voy a dibujar
al hidrógeno añadiéndose con una cuña y
luego para el otro carbono el carbono en
rojo
este de aquí este grupo metilo tendría
que estar saliendo hacia nosotros así
que el grupo metilo está ahora saliendo
hacia nosotros lo voy a dibujar con una
cuña así que nuestro grupo metilo ch3
estaría aquí bien voy a dibujar esta
molécula por acá de este modo donde el h
se aleja de nosotros en el espacio bien
ya identificamos nuestro centro girar
este carbono de aquí es nuestro centro
girar así que lo h puede tener una cuña
o puede tener guiones y por supuesto la
relación entre estos dos productos es
que son en anti o menos muy bien vamos a
hacer un ejemplo más en el que tenemos
que preocuparnos por la región química y
por la estéreo química vamos a ver este
ejemplo de aquí aquí está nuestro al que
no sabemos que esto es una hidro
votación oxidación y aquí está nuestro
doble enlace aquí tenemos un carbono y
aquí tenemos otro carbono sabemos que lo
h se añade al carbono menos
y este es por supuesto el carbono -
sustituido así que pensando únicamente
en la región química podemos dibujar la
molécula de este lado sabemos que el o h
se añade a este carbono aquí abajo y
tenemos un grupo metilo aquí voy a
resaltar a los carbonos una vez más así
que el carbono en magenta es este y el
carbono en rojo es este así que el
hidrógeno se añadirá al carbono en rojo
y podríamos dibujar ch3 aquí solo para
que quede claro noten que tenemos dos
centros espirales el carbono en rojo es
un centro quiral y el carbono en magenta
también es un centro final muy bien
ahora vamos a pensar en estéreo química
voy a dibujar uno de nuestros productos
aquí sabemos que esta es una adición sin
lo que significa que el hidrógeno y
helio h se añaden en el mismo lado ya sé
que lo h se añade a este carbono de aquí
abajo así que voy a mostrar a lo h
añadiéndose con una cuña
a dibujar una cuña aquí con el h mi
hidrógeno se añade en el otro carbono
este carbono de aquí y debido a que
tiene que añadirse en el mismo lado que
él o h lo dibujaré con una cuña muy bien
vamos a pensar en este carbono en rojo
que más está unido a este carbono tiene
unido un grupo metilo y estamos
cambiando los estados de hibridación así
que ahora puedo mostrar al grupo metilo
alejándose de nosotros en el espacio
dibujamos el ch 3 justo aquí bien este
es uno de nuestros posibles productos
vamos a dibujar el otro posible producto
que ocurre cuando el bache y el h se
añaden con viernes podemos mostrarlos
añadiéndose desde el lado opuesto así
que puedo dibujar a lo h añadiéndose con
guiones y puedo mostrar al h añadiéndose
con guiones y ahora cuando pensamos en
este carbono de aquí arriba y su estéreo
química este carbono en rojo
este grupo metilo debe venir hacia
nosotros en el espacio muy bien así que
para este carbono el grupo metilo está
viniendo hacia nosotros en el espacio
este sería un ch3 si quisieras podrías
dibujar el hidrógeno en el carbono que
tiene unido el h pero lo voy a dejar así
porque ya tenemos nuestros productos
bien entonces cuál es la relación entre
estas moléculas son en anti o menos el
uno del otro
tenemos configuraciones absolutas
opuestas en nuestros dos centros
espirales